one of the big trends in professional
sports right now is athletes want to get
paid in bitcoin that's right we've seen
tons of athletes everyone from the nfl
nba and now the ufc going ahead and
getting paid in bitcoin francis and ganu
one of the world's superstars in the ufc
is going to take half of his ufc 270
purse in bitcoin this is incredible of
course that 270 purse is gonna be a big
one and francis said bitcoin is the
future and i'm a believer now obviously
he came out with this tweet where he
said bitcoin can empower people
everywhere so i'm excited to partner
with cash app take half the person
bitcoin i want to make bitcoin more
accessible to my fans so he's also going
to give out 300 000 in bitcoin
absolutely nuts but what i really liked
was this video that he went ahead and
posted as well here it is after doing a
lot of research on bitcoin i really
believe that is the future of money man
bitcoin is valuable secure
no one can mess with it
that's why i'm taking half of my next
ufc place in bitcoin
thanks to kasha absolutely incredible to
see the ufc superstar not just saying he
thinks that bitcoin is the future of
money but that it's secure and no one
can mess with it francis understands
bitcoin and now he's gonna have a lot of
it of course now what we are watching is
the world is waking up as more
professional athletes choose to accept
bitcoin to take part of their payments
their marketing deals their salaries in
bitcoin we see things like this where it
literally is trending on twitter
paid in bitcoin francis is the latest
professional athlete to join the ranks
he's not going to be the last one
eventually every single athlete is gonna
realize bitcoin is good for business and
they want bitcoin bitcoin is not going
anywhere it's the future of money man